[موسيقى]
وزير الخارجيه المصري سامح شكري سيلتقي
بنظيره مولود شاويش اوغلو لوضع الخطوط
العريضه وتجهيز الاجراءات لعوده العلاقات
بين تركيا ومصر الى المسار الطبيعي حسب ما
اكدت صحيفه حريات التركيه فبعد ان كانت
اللقاءات بين البلدين متواصله عند المستوى
الادنى حسب رجب طيب اردوغان وصلت الى
المستوى الرفيعه وبدات العلاقات الثنائيه
الجديده بين البنات
مع الرئيس السيسي لمده 45 دقيقه واتفقنا
على ان يجتمع وزراءنا ليتم توسيع وتطوير
اللقاءات الى الاجتماع
هل ياتي افتتاح نهائيات كاس العالم في قطر
مصافحه مفاجئه اتت بواسطه قطريه
التزمت العلاقات بين تركيا ومصر منذ عام
2013 بعد ان اطاح عبد الفتاح السيسي
بالرئيس السابق محمد مرسي المنتمي لجماعه
الاخوان المسلمين اثر احتجاجات على حكمه
اردوغان المنتمي الى الاخوان المسلمين في
تركيا كان من اكبر الداعمين لمرسي